so yesterday I told you that Texas
Republican senator Ted Cruz was in New
York City for the Astros Yankees game
and he was brutally booed and heckled at
Yankee Stadium more substantively
yesterday he appeared on the New York
city-based talk show The View and it was
completely off the rails one of the most
bad faith interview performances I've
seen in a very long time and I want to
go over some of this with you because it
is so emblematic of how these folks
operate in a fact-free and also
completely a moral framework The View
co-host Anna Navarro a lifelong
Republican but an anti-trump Republican
she confronts Cruz and says how did you
go from being against Trump and him
calling your wife ugly to suddenly you
support the guy take a look at this
frankly don't know how you'll get over
your wife being called ugly I don't know
how you get over those kind of
calamities against your father but you
obviously have gotten over it today
you're saying a very different tune so
tell us were you lying then or are you
lying now yeah that's that's a loaded
question there I think a lot of people
have the same question it's a very
different Ted Cruz that we're seeing
we are and we do not agree that that's
very different Ted Cruz than today what
I would say is this in 2016 we had a
primary where Donald Trump and I beat
the living crap out of each other I'll
tell you Heidi laughed when he said that
my father laughed by the way my dad
didn't just kill Kennedy he's got Jimmy
Hoffman Ted it was so funny when Donald
Trump called me ugly
but rom-com a buried in the backyard it
was idiotic and we went after each other
and at the end of the day he won and I
had a decision to make in November of
2016. yes am I going to stand on
principles and maybe be on the outs with
the president or do I want to start
sucking up to keep access to power he'd
been elected president I got a
responsibility to represent 30 million
Texans I could have decided my feelings
are hurt I'm going to take the ball and
go home and not do my job but if I was
prepared to do that I better be prepared
to resign from my job because I have a
responsibility so what I did is I is I
went and said listen we have an
opportunity to make a difference for
this country and I want to roll up my
sleeves and lead the fight to actually
deliver on promises we were talking a
minute ago about the incredible booming
economy we saw seven million people get
off of food stamps seven million people
and food stamps does not actually
address how and why Ted Cruz got in line
with Trump and remember that if
everybody laughed about Trump calling
Heidi Cruz ugly back in 2016 why was it
that in the immediate aftermath Ted Cruz
referred to Trump as a sniveling coward
because of those comments and said leave
Heidi the hell alone if everybody
laughed and had a good time after that
why did he do it Anna Navarro also
confronts Ted Cruz with some of the
specific things he said about Trump what
you said about him back in 2016 during
the campaign let's take a look I'm
trying to tell you what I really think
about
[Music]
true
doesn't know the difference between
truth and lies he lies
practically every word that comes out of
his mouth the man is utterly amoral if
morality does not exist for him true
yeah so I have to ask you because you
know I'm married to a Cuban man I
frankly don't know how you'll get over
your wife being called ugly I don't know
how you get over those kind of calendars
okay so then they go into the part that
we already saw another interesting
moment during this was that Ted Cruz
just could not be in New York City and
not get heckled climate activists
interrupted the interview and then
Whoopi Goldberg says let us do our job
and it just gets completely crazy it's
very simple if you look at inflation the
Nobel Laureate Economist Milton Friedman
explained in the United States inflation
has one cause and one cause only
foreign
inflation in the United States has one
cause and one cause of it and that is
when the federal government spends too
much money okay we have seen trillions
and trillions of dollars spent by Joe
Biden the Democrats just last year last
year the federal government took in four
trillion dollars in taxes
in history we've ever taken in the
problem is we spent nearly seven
trillion dollars and that's what we do
cover climates
ladies ladies excuse us let us do our
job let us do our job we hear what you
have to say but you gotta go
[Applause]
all right so then there they start to
get kicked out but somehow then they get
more energy and then they're back and
then they end up having to mute
everything and cut to commercial the
biggest reason people at home are saying
okay is my life better today than it was
two years ago and I think for the vast
majority of Americans the answer is no
[Applause]
all right so total chaos on The View uh
ABC spokesperson put out a statement
saying that three people in the audience
interrupted The View and they were
escorted out these interviews are not
going particularly well for Ted Cruz but
I have to tell you what if you see this
Through The Eyes of right Wingers and
we're going to see things through the
eyes of right Wingers in a moment you
see a guy whose speech they are trying
to suppress
and that it is unhinged people doing it
so you know you and I know that this guy
is the lowest of the low truly but
understand that the right Wingers see
this and they go look at those liberals
they don't want to let them speak in
suppressing speech and next we are going
to look exactly at
what is going on in the minds of some of
these people